martin biron au christian dufour hélène
buzzetti bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir deux
sujets ce soir j'ai pris un peu de thym
que le docteur de serre tout à l'heure
pour justement au sujet du premier sujet
dont je vous parlais lors de vaccination
est ce qu'on devrait pas ouvrir le coeur
il dit à bombay des gens qui sont plus
poké qui ont enfermé déficience
intellectuelle outils succéderont
devrait passer avant peut-être des gens
de 60 65 ans martin biron docteur de
serre finalement la fin a dit oui oui
effectivement ça ça a pris un peu plus
de temps mais il a dit on va sûrement
recommandé sa au ministre mais c'est le
ministre qui décide on en parlait hier
cette mine est visible mais il le
souligner encore c'est le ministre qui
décide et il y a eu des élus et des
ministres qui ont poussé dans ce sens là
très tôt jeune homme
1 parce que dans ce cas là c'est assez
évident c'est lionel carmant qui est
responsable de la santé des services
sociaux qui a eu des discussions avec
monsieur dubé sur l'idée de 2,2 de
prioriser les clientèles qui était
déficiente puis aussi les personnes qui
sont dus troubles de l'autisme
il y avait une ouverture pour con con
qu'on les place dans le plan de
vaccination mais qu'un monsieur paré est
arrivé à la mi janvier on se demandait
si on aura assez de doses pour se rendre
jusqu'à la fin mars et la structure
s'est fait dans ce contexte là et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui on la sent la
pression au gouvernement et il ya eu
dans différentes villes différentes
discussions et ça va se faire cela dit
je vous dirais qu'ils vont tracer une
ligne parce que ce qu'on me disait
aujourd'hui c'est bon mais est ce que on
vaccine les personnes déficientes par
exemple mais ce qu'on doit vacciner et
prochaine chez terra alors il ya tout ce
qu'on veut organiser c'est une opération
qui est quand même assez complexe qui
demande beaucoup de logistique est ce
qu'on dit c'est ça va se faire mais ils
votent racine ly bon mais ça va se faire
comme ça se fait ailleurs en grande
bretagne comme en ontario a dit ontario
et les bambins bravo vous parlez si loin
et on s'est juste christian duffau oui
en fait j'ai trouvé ce bond en entrevue
avec le dr de serres parce que vous êtes
revenu à la charge d'autres vivent à
charge l'autre vice versa parce qu'ils
voulaient pas trop le dire et il admis à
la fin que il recommanderait
éventuellement des exceptions mais comme
le dit martine sq avait d'intéressant
aussi dans le fait que ça a pris du
temps avant que ça aboutisse c'est que y
attirer l'attention sur le fait que
l'opérationnalisation de socle pour être
plus compliqué qu'on le pensait on leur
prête arbitrer entre différentes
maladies
à partir du moment où enfin une
exception il faut tracer la ligne comme
dit martin les des gens aujourd'hui qui
parlait peut-être de certains
travailleurs essentiels qui pourraient
être mis à des exceptions donc on touche
là une question de justice dans la
mesure où c'est plus facile à régler
absolument parce qu'il ya plus de
vaccins qu'on pensait voilà on aurait
mais attention ce moment il n'y a pas de
vaccins pour tout le monde la
distinction selon la gelée terminera
mais n'était juste qu'un certain point
donc pour pour conclure je dirais qu'il
faut s'attendre à ce que dans l'école
est plus évident il ya une exception
mais reste que l'opérationnalisation et
quand même pas si simple qu'elle
enverrait au prime abord
de prime abord mais rien n'est simple
dans tout ça puis comme dit martin en
ontario le font ailleurs ils le font
mais écoutez il faut il faut avoir un
car il faut être sensible à la situation
difficile que vivent ces gens par contre
moi ce qui m'étonne un peu celle a
priori de tout ça on semble penser
qu'une fois que ces personnes qui ont
des vies plus difficiles qui ont des
contraintes supplémentaires une fois
qu'ils seront vaccinés deviendra un peu
plus libres dans leurs mouvements dans
les activités auxquelles ils pourraient
assister et 6 ans qui est un peu étrange
à mon point de vue parce que rappelons
le que ce vaccin il ne vous protège pas
il ne vous empêche pas de contracter le
coronavirus et vous empêche de
développer la copie de la maladie
une forme grave de la maladie et même
peut-être d'en mourir il n'y a aucune
données qui démontrent que une fois que
vous êtes vacciné vous pouvez pas
obtenir contracté ce virus ou même le
propager alors malgré tout ce qu'on
semble penser même si ces gens
deviennent vacciner est ce que vraiment
il est réaliste de penser qu'ils
pourraient continuer à faire des
activités ou retourner comme ça entre
leurs foyers et leurs maisons familiales
très librement sans être isolé des
autres résidents par exemple j'ai un
petit doute là dessus et je trouve que
l'action on n'a pas beaucoup clarifier
les faits à ce sujet en tout cas oui
mais en tout cas ça aiderait on s'entend
qu'elle en tiendrait larmes que nous
avons la seule c'est la vaccination si
quelqu'un reçoit ces surdoses il est
quand même plus libres d'aller au parc
ils s'exposent moins à des dangers
mortels
quand il va jouer au parc oui mais dans
la mesure où si cette personne elle même
n'était pas vulnérables de contracter
une forme grave de la maladie et où d'en
mourir
le vaccin il est surtout utile pour
protéger les autres dans la communauté
et donc en ce sens de continuer à
côtoyer d'autres personnes qui elles ne
seraient toujours pas vaccinées ça
donnerait un problème
bon moi je pense que ce qui est acquis
c'est qu'il va falloir faire des
exceptions pour l'école et les plus
évidentes
je pense que tout le monde est convaincu
de ça mais c'est de tracer la ligne
parce qu'à partir du moment où on trouve
la brèche ces cartes va voir d'autres
demandent où s'arrêter ce me suis dit ça
me frappe est évident le vine je pense à
l'émission de michel chenaud j'ai parlé
des travailleurs est essentielle au
travers et sa soeur née dans autre chose
on est plus dans dans le sanitaire
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut bien
ficelé ça mais en prenant pour acquis
qu'il va avoir des exceptions parce que
entre autres ce que je vous ai le
brouillard il faut le dire elle a touché
pas mal tout le monde avec elle comme
incarner ce problème lancé la carte et
le problème avec des arguments mais
josée legault
ce qu'elle nous disait parce qu'elle le
vit moi j'ai une étude ici je vais vous
envoyer l'un d'eux ça vous intéresse et
qui développe j'ai pas le temps mais qui
développe et qui répond à certaines de
vos interrogations sur en croit la
vaccination de gens plus vulnérables qui
ont des ddd retard et manteaux etc
en quoi ça va les libérer et ses
habitudes assez complète bref hockey
deuxième sujet je disais deux sujets les
élections depuis deux jours
quand ton pied là nous étiez là quand on
ne sut que le dépôt du budget selon le
global être déposée mi avril elle même
peut-être troisième d'avril on verra moi
la première idée puis les clercs qui met
à part au visage c'est ça y est c'est
sûr il doit aller en campagne électorale
mi juin je vous fais entendre qu'il a
dit à paul arcand ce matin il est très
très très très loin de fermer la porte
mais ce truc d'eau en campagne j'exclus
absolument rien qui les autres partis
refusent de passer les projets de lois
qui vont aider les gens si on se voit
l'unité à cause des jeux comme les
consommateurs sont en train de jouer
maintenant avec l'aide médicale à mourir
je peux pas écarté toute possibilité on
a besoin d'avoir un parlement qui
fonctionne pour aider les canadiens
pendant sept ans des miss
monsieur trudeau et c'est selon l'humeur
du jour de ce bidouiller une fenêtre
électorale moi j'ai dit au premier
ministre si vous voulez vraiment porter
l'odieux face à 38 millions de personnes
que vous préférez défendre vos petits
intérêts partisans
plutôt que de protéger les québécois et
les canadiens contre lampant d'être
contre la pandémie
il va y avoir une facture qui vont venir
avec alors hélène notre collègue paul
s'interrogeait dans la presse matin en
disant pourquoi les conservateurs bloc
autant de projets de loi importants aux
yeux des libéraux est ce qu'ils ne
donnent pas justement l'argument massue
à monsieur toure jafza elle parlement
est bloquée je vais aller je veux en
appeler aux canadiens ben oui c'est en
fait c'est la grande question on ne
comprend pas vraiment la stratégie
conservatrice et effectivement ça donne
des munitions à monsieur trudeau sur
l'aide médicale à mourir notamment mais
aussi ce fameux projet de loi qui ferait
en sorte que les voyageurs ne pourraient
pas bénéficier lors du 1000 $ pour se
mettre en quarantaine
ce projet de loi l'oeil il est toujours
aux feuilletons mais il n'est pas
débattue elle n'est pas adoptée
ça tarde alors monsieur trudeau est en
train de se bâtir un thème électoral
parfait le pour pouvoir aller en
élections vous parliez du budget et leur
dit je vous avais 6000 le scénario le
budget le 22 avril le jour la terre ça
marchera pas ça arrive pas je retire mes
paroles parce que ce 22 avril là c'est
le jour le jour choisi par joe biden
pour obtenir un fameux sommet sur le
climat
monsieur trudeau a l'intention d'y
assister il sera question de nouvelles
mesures pour combattre les changements
climatiques donc ce qu'on me dit moi en
coulisses c'est que on voudra aller il
soit cinq jours avant ou cinq jours
après ce sommet américains pour pauvres
et fajr ombrage si vous voulez à la
faire mais ça nous met quand même
tardivement au mode avril et après dans
ce budget qui aurait à peu près 100
milliards de nouvelles mesures c'est ce
qu'on nous a promis et bien et quoi de
mieux que de dire je n'ai pas de mandat
pour dépenser autant d'argent
je vais demander un nouveau mandat aux
électeurs surtout que je peux rien faire
parce que les méchants conservateur
maman page
ce qui les christie en train de préparer
en fait le scénario il n'a pas besoin de
se faire battre il va lui-même allé voir
le ou la gouverneure générale qui sera
nommé dans quelques jours la nouvelle où
le nouveau pour dire barbes et c'est
plus c'est plus possible
allons sur wii je pense que c'est
possible et on critique souvent justin
trudeau surtout dans le québec
francophone là il manifeste une habileté
certaine parce qu'il est à l'offensive
il prend on sent que la possibilité
d'élections devient de plus en plus
probable propres pour certaines et puis
dans le dossier des vaccins passe
quelque chose le dossier des vaccins ça
s'est amélioré le moral des canadiens et
des québécois immédiat au fond c'est
monsieur hervé dos turquie qui va avoir
à prouver
jusqu'à quel point il est fonctionnel en
politique jusqu'à quel point il est bon
si l'on teste c'est son grand test mais
en même temps on parle on parle c'est
normal mais je tenais tout nous aussi il
va décider
jusqu'à la fin il peut changer d'idée
bien souvent c'est pas sûr encore qui
voit qui va aller en élections mais ces
cars que j'écoute l entrevue avec
monsieur argent
ce matin je des chapeaux justin trudeau
parce qu'en fait ils préparent le
terrain totalement mais en même temps il
peut encore tout fait rire toute la
marge dont on va voir comment ça allait
vous pas ils sont deux comme tous les
partis obsessivement tout les jours tous
les jours savoir ce que les gens
accepteraient ou non comme ça sur le dos
n'est important de martin comment les
canadiens accepteraient cette décision
en pleine pandémie quand même et puis on
va t'en sortie de crise monsieur trudeau
a quand même tracé deux lignes dans le
sable concernant la vaccination le 30
mars et septembre alors la première
ligne sera
régler c'est à dire que si à livrer
l'ensemble des vaccins et qu'il ya une
ouverture ben il faut probablement en
tenir compte
le morceau de casting du québec va être
important rappelez-vous en 2019 comment
monsieur legault avait dit qu'il
n'interviendrait pas dans la campagne
mais il est intervenu à cinq reprises
toujours sur le même sujet de la loi sur
la laïcité faut s'attendre à ce que
monsieur legault interviennent encore
dans cette loi là certainement que son
thème de prédilection sera les
transferts en santé
monsieur trudeau a déjà mis la table
avec mélanie joly sur le français alors
il va y avoir une
une belle danse ici et hélène en
quelques secondes les sondages montrent
qu'ils pourraient gagner il ne faut pas
être naïf c'est tout si certains des
facteurs importants
oui surtout et surtout il faut garder à
l'esprit que si on attend à l'automne
les choses pouvaient être pour être
radicalement différente si la
vaccination a bien roulé les gens
penseront plus à la pandémie
on va regarder vers l'avenir et ça
pourrait être meilleure pour les
conservateurs donc des fois
mieux vaut y aller maintenant quand
c'est possible que plus tard france à
risque d'être moins bon ben on sera là
si jamais ça arrive merci beaucoup
à bientôt pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit